last year the auction house christie's
sold a jpeg by the artist beeble for a
record-breaking 69 million dollars
people's sale hit the art market like an
earthquake for many the sale of this nft
represents a revolution for the art
market since it was the first piece of
art sold by a major auction house that
does not physically exist there's this
um real gold rush feel to sort of being
on the ground floor of something dynamic
and with that comes a lot of risk and i
think the art market is you know still
trying to figure out where this will go
but i don't think it's going anywhere
so to you out there online thank you so
how are nfts transforming the art market
and if this technology goes mainstream
who stands to benefit let's give him a
cyber quad
this is niche markets
a series about small lesser-known
markets that despite their size
punch well above their weight
[Music]
in 2021 the concept of a non-fungible
token or nft entered the zeitgeist nfts
in 2021 were an incredibly important
milestone it has a really revolutionary
impact on the art business nfts for me
it's a new genre of art digital art has
existed for decades i think we will
always think of a before and after in
terms of nfts nfts are digital tokens or
vouchers of authenticity that represent
digital or real-life art or collectibles
an nft is essentially a receipt that you
can never throw away if you need proof
that you own a thing an nft is one way
to lock that down forever although nfts
have been around for a few years it
wasn't until 2021 when they really began
to attract widespread attention
so we are in my living room and we're
watching the closing of the auction the
artist behind this piece of work is mike
winkelmann better known as beeple 69
million i think it probably means
digital artists here to stay
christy said the sale of every days
makes people among the top three most
valuable living artists a fact made all
the more remarkable since every days
began bidding at 100
it was truly a watershed moment it
introduced nfts into the auction world
in 2021 which was really the biggest
headline for our business for him to
come in with essentially a jpeg collage
and outsell frida kahlo and salvador
dali i mean the art market couldn't wrap
its head around what we were
experiencing and it was definitely a
marker of a brand new world
artist cam rackham spends his days in
his southern california studio creating
nfts
i've been an artist for 18 years i
started dabbling with nfts during the
pandemic
i thought it was going to be two weeks
and it just went on and on
i watched um
my art shows melt away before the
pandemic rackham's income came mostly
from gallery sales and commissions but
lockdowns put him on unemployment and
forced him to pivot his business
nfts have massively changed my life
let's give him
a little
wall street bull sign i didn't plan for
that or expect that there we go
but i went from marginally successful
painter to a full-time nft maker
rackham is the artist behind a
collection of nfts known as wall street
bulls which is comprised of 10 000
cartoon bull nfts this one has a pipe
this one has a laser eye this one has a
goatee
maybe a beard each of the wall street
bull nfts parodies different aspects of
today's social media field retail
trading culture aoc we gave her her
famous taxa rich dress and she's got her
commie horns in her bernie tattoo the
collection was produced in partnership
with the team behind the satirical
instagram account wall street memes
which takes much of its inspiration from
the popular wall street bets subreddit
that was at the center of last year's
gamestop mania
we thought
with being bullish on the market the
bull as a character made a lot of sense
to us that's jp morgan and john d
rockefeller
although the sales that have grabbed
many of the headlines have to do with
specific works of art like beeples every
days or humanone some of the most
popular nfts bought and sold today are
part of collections the really cool
thing about how nfts have really
exploded is that it's given sort of all
kinds of art a chance to shake out and
find its own subcategory right so you
have the apes and the doge coins and the
various animal creatures right there
almost similar to being in a part of a
club
nft collections tend to follow a release
strategy similar to sneaker drops they
come in limited quantities depend on
sky-high demand and stir speculative
crazes in the secondary market the
secondary market is like it's the
probably the most beautiful part of the
nft selling spectrum thanks to a few
lines of code embedded within an nft
artists are guaranteed a cut of any and
all future sales of their work in
perpetuity now
as an artist you can collect a royalty
as a creator a developer you do get kind
of what you deserve finally
rackham told the journal that the wall
street bulls collection sold out in 32
minutes netting the team behind it an
initial profit of 2.6 million dollars of
which his take-home was 726 000
since the project went live on october
27th rackham said he has made an
additional 62 thousand dollars in
royalties we've been in this kind of
auction house corporate contemporary
world for a very long time nfts are so
much more democratic
there we go we come to a place where
artists have more say over where their
works go
and they have more you know they're
getting a cut of resales and they're
knowing where everything is
i mean certainly that does shift the
balance of power a little bit in the
favor of the little guy and of the
artist as as opposed to the power
brokers these new buyers are far younger
than those who typically participate in
high priced auctions 75 percent of the
people who participate in our nft sales
this year were entirely new to
christie's our average nft bar is 42
years old that's more than 10 years
younger than the buyers across
categories ahead of you in hong kong 16
is here thank you to cater to this new
clientele the 255 year old auction house
changed its payment policies we had to
expedite
our readiness to accept cryptocurrency
because it was absolutely demanded by
some of the avid nft buyers and now
we're delighted that we're actually
accepting cryptocurrency not only for
nft works but for works across other
categories
the much anticipated sequel
to people's first offering here at
christie's in 2021 christie sold around
150 million dollars in nfts or eight
percent of its contemporary art sales
we think nfts are here to stay we've had
great conversations with so many artists
musical artists visual artists so i
think the
sky is the limit
we're in the moment 24 million
25 online